once the train leaves the station of  cuckoo Ville it does not ever come back  I don't know why do you cry in the  teaser I'll tell you this it has nothing  to do with terror it does make it seem  like that but out you all eat her it's a  little game for you it's the shirt right  it's the dress jacket my dress you're  freaky is what you are this is low  Thanks well it's related to Kelly's  Siward moment and you screaming it  who knows he'll I mean you're in a limo  crying or a car crying good well you  know I don't rewire things on the show  so writers go  is it something one of the other women  says that takes you to that place I will  tell you this uh I had a visceral  reaction to the events of that evening  that I could never have predicted I  couldn't have predicted the events or my  response to them I don't apologize for  them but after it happens I'd be happy  to talk to you about we just have to  have you back